Oh
that's undoubtedly true the question
though is also why it weren't there more
women involved in in those systems and
will women ever be involved in the same
way the evidence we have is that women
seem to not want to compete at that
level with that kind of violence over a
lifetime there was just a study done of
women in in in Silicon Valley and about
a third of the women leave very quickly
from the competition another third have
babies and they never go back and the
ones who persist are relatively more
modest in their activities than the
males are and I think we have to
acknowledge the fact that that males
tend to be somewhat more bellicose and
aggressive whether it's good for them to
generate these collateralized debt
obligation instruments that have caused
us such tremendous grief I'm not sure
that's gender specific but the idea of
making all that money and being of high
status and having the money to give for
your kids and so on all of that those
things are associated with the male
career by and large so a lot of those
people who made those huge salaries had
two or three kids in private school and
they had a whole array of expenses which
were really high and in general I think
it's the case that females don't go for
that kind of money because they don't
want to there's a lot of talk about a
glass ceiling and so on but for example
a Harvard Business School did a study
some years ago and I'm afraid I can't
remember the details but it turns out
that a large large percentage of the
graduates don't do business at all they
go into the labor force for a while and
then they leave they either quit because
they don't like fighting for the corner
suite or they have kids and they have a
priority and they serve that priority so
we're not going to repeal biology and so
long as you
a tournament area called Wall Street or
whatever else you want to call it where
a whole lot of really eager males can
get together and fight over sources then
you have to really regulate and I think
and this is what President Obama is
concerned about in fact he's in New York
City as we speak to talk to people about
that issue and speaking prime
ideological i prime ideological II I
think he's got an interesting challenge
but also a good point
overwhelmingly when we look at say
sexual want ads in newspapers it's
decreasing now because of the internet
but in the when these things first came
out women men would always ask for women
who were affectionate warm etc fertile
good-looking women invariably asked for
men who were reliable and quote unquote
professional by professional they meant
something's going to provide a general
and a genuine and and a predictable
stream of income for me and for our
children and women look for that old
time women are always trying to find
guys who are slightly older and slightly
richer than they are and that is not
being mean it's makes a lot of sense
because women do have babies most women
still do and when they have babies they
have needs there's a lot of discussion
about the so-called 77 cents on the
dollar that women earn and President
Obama has repeated this nonsense himself
repeat it's true women earned 77 cents
on the dollar but the reason is that
they're out of the labor force for five
to eight years and if you assume a three
percent increase per annum there's your
for eight years there's your difference
and so the reason is that women make
choices that men don't make don't have
to make and the consequence is that
males will be in the tournament in Wall
Street however it's now changed because
of the credential problem that i
mentioned that is that guys are not
graduating from desirable schools to the
extent they used to and so now in big
cities such as New York Toronto Chicago
LA etc women between 20 and 35 earned
more money than men in that age group
now there's a good reason for that again
not only are women better at the school
system which favors them it seems but
any woman who's at college now who's
coming to maturity in the modern world
knows
not only has she to study to support
herself but she's studying for two
because she may well have a child and
she may well have no provider to take
care of that child and her so she better
get a good job good credential so she'll
be in shape to do this forty percent of
babies born in the United States and in
Europe are born to women who are not
legally married now some of them are
living with guys and the connections may
be made and they may be durable but the
fact is that the idea of so many women
having babies on their own risking that
they may have to do this by themselves
is I think very revealing and it
suggests a great deal about what they
think of the guys they just don't trust
them
it really depends on the perspective on
biology there has been in the whole
women studies world a notion that sex
roles are the result of which magazines
you read in which sitcom you watch and
that it's all confection it's not
indigenous out of the organism and so
that and the idea of patriarchy is if
there were a bunch of guys sitting
around and doing their very best to keep
women down again possibly true and
certainly true in a whole series of
events but the fact is that I think that
it hasn't worked that that approach the
call of women's studies approach men's
tennis approach which is basically a
branch plant of the Women's Studies
programs that hasn't worked to yield for
us a society of equal men and women
equally enjoying equally profiting from
their educational experience and so it
seemed to a number of us it was time to
actually start again when you have a
situation in which two-thirds of the
graduates of an institution are female
and it's supposed to be for everybody
you entitled to ask why is this trip
necessary how did it get this way and so
we were rather innocently saying just
let's review the matter we're not
content with the result it hasn't worked